[Music]
hello welcome to honest trailer
commentaries for the witch yeah I'm
Spencer Gilbert Joestar dan Morello
today we're gonna be giving you our
behind-the-scenes thought process what
we really thought about that show mostly
good things and if you stick around
you'll see some deleted scenes
afterwards we'll respond to questions
from viewers like you and we will tease
next week's honest trailer the witch
boys mm-hmm what do y'all think well I'm
not gonna be like the Entertainment
Weekly guy and pass final judgment after
only sing part of it I saw I watched the
first half of it oh okay and provided my
input and notes into the trailer I
didn't have time to finish the rest but
the first half I will say I was number
one very confused by the time jumping
yes very very confused by it and number
two it's we it's an odd show it's an odd
show mm-hmm
very strange okay so odd well Joe you
may not watch things in on the joke or
not I guess yeah yeah some tonal some
tonal shifting - Joe you watched it
multiple times I made up for Dan by I've
watched this series through two and a
half times currently on watch number dos
or trace sorry my Spanish is rusty I
love this show it's so weird and it
rolls around in its own weirdness it's
it's like we say at the end where it's
like if you needed images put to these
words then this is your show and I guess
this was my show just feels like a big
dumb fun slightly darker big-budget
episode of Xena
yeah qui se yeah I mean I was
predisposed to like it I'm a big fan of
the second and third game having played
the first one and
and the first book so I wasn't as
confused you know I could tell you what
a Witcher is first time in I was like I
don't know what I was still like
enjoying myself I knew who ciri and
yennefer and tris and all these cats
yeah yeah so yeah it didn't really faze
me and I love the harkening back to well
shows like Xena which are harkening back
to shows like kung fu which are
harkening back to westerns which are
probably hearkening back to like cave
paintings of like the badass who went to
the other cave for a week imagine all of
those in one show yeah yeah I love that
Masonic stuff and this does I remember
reading some interview with the
showrunner the books do have a natural
ending point that they're headed towards
that they don't plan on going beyond
into videogame territory so even though
it's episodic this is heading somewhere
there are destinies to be fulfilled as
they would say on the show over again so
yeah I hope that this doesn't get the
Netflix two seasons and out curse which
I feel like they do to save money mm-hmm
because they sign most of their talent
to like a two season deal I mean yes
everyone starts to negotiate and
interesting so it's up to viewers like
you
to make the winter so popular ten
minutes at a time to just watch for 30
seconds and Netflix counts it their
annual view report ding yeah anything
else before you dive in I still I cannot
underscore enough how confused I was
about whether the show understands how
campy it is or does not understand it
changed from scene to scene the
challenge is the the tonal jump that I
think you're having a hard time with
this pilot versus Episode two which is
like a huge band-aid rip because that's
true yeah
pilot is like really hey it has the best
sword fight and it is a lot more grim
dark mm-hm and then episode two is just
like you're ready for wacky here we go
and so I think right there that's the
biggest tonal shift so you really have
to I don't know just get on board with
that too and kind of
okay here it is yeah it's like should I
laugh with it should I laugh at it is it
laughing at me I think there's something
for everyone yeah yeah exact the beauty
of The Witcher is that needs to be you
this is halfway through the run perhaps
and the final four episodes that that
question is answered for me yeah a lot
of fun stuff you're missing actually
yeah they come together well at the end
and my favorite episode is like you know
we're off to slay the dragon mm-hmm
everyone sawed in two teams see I
represent because we try to get a nice
different viewpoints on the show I
represent the Netflix viewer that
watches four episodes and it's curious
about what's going on yeah but I'm not
gonna pass final judgment on the show
because again like that Entertainment
Weekly person that's not fair
it isn't fair to how I feel so far in
their defense and I like the show in
their defense if you didn't like the
first for the second four aren't gonna
change your mind
sure but as quasi professional critic I
would not then review the show very
negative oh yeah yeah I could tell from
the bit that I've seen what the rest of
this you can't tell you how many honest
trailers I would have loved to just stop
a third of the way through the movie
anyway I get it from here yeah you gotta
suffer through yeah you do I hate to
watch TV shut up and watch so shut up
and watch TV now let's watch TV of TV
and talk about the TV yeah watched
[Music]
based on the books you've been meaning
to read
they got spun off into games you've been
meaning to finish there some does series
that's meant to be the next Game of
Thrones but ended up more like the next
Xena Warrior Princess I ain't mad at it
The Witcher get ready for the most
watched Netflix show ever because they
changed on account the views as you said
possible we alluded to that the way they
changed it is it used to be
was it 70% percent of one episode
counted as a view for a TV show and then
they changed it to like two minutes yeah
isn't this how Facebook ruined
everything
yes 900 but it's when they were like if
you scroll past something yeah and and
there's enough time to blink your eye
while you're scrolling past it that's a
view yeah all metrics are based on
nothing yeah and then everyone pivoted
the video yeah yeah it's a house of
cards built unless it is I'm gonna save
you from the comments section you're
spinning you have a piece of headphone
fuzz on your neck right there oh that's
just a vampire hickey okay let's move on
I just could see the rest of the
comments section being he should get
that mulching yes exactly thank you so
as you enter a sprawling fantasy world
that seems pretty complicated on the
surface but boils down to a vaguely
Polish tokine with swears there's
something strange in your ball or woods
who you gonna call a Witcher that's too
bad highly trained what's up the voice
here sure I love it
his voice yeah what's our on this voice
again I don't know if if I'm supposed
it's I know is it mocking is it it's
like a self-serious thing that's like in
contrast or is it so because I feel like
if I'm supposed to take that seriously
than it's ridiculous
but if it's supposed to be in contrast
to everything else then it's brilliant I
can't decide if he's brilliant it's like
Billy Zane and Titan
I cannot decide if Henry cavils
performance in this movie in the show is
terrible or brilliant
I thought that I was like what are you
doing cavil until his first well-timed
f-bomb yeah and then the first time he
dropped one of those I was like oh he
knows exactly what he's doing
okay I'm leaning toward great yeah but
again it is one of those things that
it's hard to classify particularly as
you tried to get into the show yeah well
he's um he's doing a voice pretty much
based on the video game voice actor I
I'm just pulling out of my ass but it's
he sounds like the guy who does the
voice in the games okay but he's like
he's grooming it up even more
yeah like even more gravel to it it
sounds like he's doing an impression of
the games so you know there you go do
you like your gravelly voice I like his
gravelly voice yeah very impressive that
the depth of merit oh it's very yeah
yeah real throaty yeah you learned that
at Juilliard I don't know if that's true
your lent the gym yeah all right let's
keep y'all learn that getting swole yeah
that's too bad highly trained you
killing machines who every [ __ ] in the
land wants to pick a fight with for some
reason yeah mutant son of a [ __ ] better
yeah did not know about each other I've
always wanted to play with one why right
along with the titular witcher geralt
as henry cavill mean bugs his way
through the continent searching for the
minimum number of syllables required to
carry a series
expressive some review from these three
words on his destiny will be tied to
Siri a baby Yoda with the power of
scream oh power scream left the Hogwarts
to deep state made by ploy to go live by
her own rules
selling boner weed and tagging along is
the foppish bard character who everyone
hates my name is Julian Alfred with a
song or two that everyone begrudgingly
admits is actually pretty good toss a
coin 7 fantasy realms have to deal with
their own version of John Mayer Oh buzz
oui there was discussion about who was
the appropriate oh it's her part it was
like fits these exact specifications I
mean I'm talking like early Oddie's John
Mayer given like really obnoxious
interviews to every anyone who would
listen and yes and dating all the pop
stars and stuff like that but then like
now he's like the guitar player for the
Grateful Dead and like you did Chappelle
show and you're like and you're like oh
he's really good at guitar look
everyone's got an arc some of the songs
were admittedly quite catchy yeah this
show
owes whoever wrote the melody the tunes
not from the game is it think so okay
cuz this shows that song yeah because I
games also have the every time an action
sequence kicks in is like the I'll call
it Eastern Europe I think kind of rips
but it's it's a weird Liebig aesthetic
right now too because like the last
Kingdom on Netflix uses a very similar
score and yeah I don't know it's big
right now man it's just real it's
happening yeah that's how you know
someone's about to mess you
up in the games as the yodeling starts
oh yeah like oh I got to start running
yeah yeah but as for characterize this
guy is based on a again a game and books
character name like what's his name not
buttercup dandelion but I didn't and
they aren't cut okay they didn't want a
name in that a guy dandelion I guess so
yes yeah yeah go for it you're a weird
change to make but yeah I think that the
the core characters are all good except
Siri maybe more interesting later right
now she's just kind of girl lost in
woods you know right now she's just
drinking bone broth yeah forgetting
right I'm forgetting that's about where
I jumped off yeah she was forgetting
yeah drink it forget she's getting that
elf drink potions why a lot of people
drink but yeah little extreme
there you go that is a weird episode
that's one where I was like we didn't
need to go that force less forest
alright let's keep going
I guess even fantasy realms have to deal
with their own version of John Mayer
that sucks
watch the action drama and complete lack
of comedy unfold across the typical
episode where Carol comes across a
problem he doesn't want to get involved
in I won't choose to John's gonna say no
then totally gets involved in it and
then while series runs through some
woods boringly Jennifer's dress comes
off then we switch timelines only you
don't realize it since half the
characters don't age so just enjoy an
awesome sword fight yeah cause that's
why the alternate timelines or multiple
timelines don't work even for me as
someone who was primed to know what was
happening right they need to give say
what you will about JJ Abrams but he
gave c-3po that red arm so that you knew
some time had passed
yeah somebody needed like like a scar or
like
in an outfit or a haircut or something
that you could tell the difference
between the timelines because gerelds
like a hundred something at yennefer is
probably the same like they don't change
based on what time line you're in and
little women even like the new version
you had characters who looked exactly
the same like they were aged upper age
down but it's a very subtle thing not
even very subtle it did some very neat
time period had a distinct look and they
each wore those shirts with their age on
them yes if they're aged but like Year's
Eve glasses of the year they were in
their surrounding were hair differently
and that with the color timing was a
little different and just color Cerrone
sure she can't hear at these on I know
the coloring was more lush when you were
in the past and there was a little
Bleecker and it was just a very subtle
thing to let you know and then here I'm
just like watching and then she's in
she's in which school and she's not and
then she's working with she's like it's
been decades I'm like decades and I
don't need think spoon-fed to me but
there's also like that was about to
catch up to that movie they do have the
issue of introducing a concept and then
explaining it episodes later because of
the timeline thais it's like there's one
transition that they do really well
where you go okay time jump and that's
when you see the city's skyline and I'm
like walks by it and now it's burning
which was really effective but also if
that had been like their go-to every
time there was a time line up it
probably would have gotten kind of funny
give someone just like like special
edition it's like you just have a CGI
monster walk across the screen yeah
meanwhile in the burning city or just go
60s Batman have like a spinning winter
face
coins being tossed at the screen yeah
alright let's get going characters don't
age
so just enjoy an awesome sword fight
really good fight Korea yeah actually
the the choreographer who did the pilot
fight didn't do the rest of the series
for season 2
they're coming in as the main
choreography Asura an actor yeah yeah
but the game of thrones kind of ruined
us for fantasy special effects oh and
you see a dragon on screen and this one
and it looks a little more no it's a
little more dragon like there's like
more ps1 or dragon heart and then drogon
or viscera I'm the last one logical
watched war yeah I like that actually if
he had to kill Sean Connery's - actually
the crossover you didn't see coming -
etosha coin to me oh I hate to see a go
but I love to watch you leave you ask
her that song slaps like I do
was that Hunchback I've been hearing I
shot which has only came once a day
character I enjoyed the Hunchback boobs
I imagine that the women or whatever
whoever's watching would have liked to
see Henry cavils but in the pale
moonlight is every five minutes in our
household by my wife she's just like
that many tubs just not one cheek the
inequality with the nudity was
almost offensively surprising from
balance that that was another sort of
like standout thing to me because
especially when you get to the end they
do some really cool character work with
all the lady wizards and there's a few
great episodes where all of them have
these really cool little arcs and
sequences and spoilers for The Witcher
it's very like kind of Seven Samurai II
where it's kind of Last Stand II so
you're gonna get your shorthand here's
why you care about this person so it's a
female showrunner who has all these
really cool and diverse female
characters but then like a game of
Thrones just amount of boobs it's like
it's such a weird jarring balance to
meet where it's like almost like the
rest of the show I mean which I mean
then they're being consistent right yeah
I guess so yeah most consistently
inconsistent show love it all right
let's keep going we named the dog Gerald
Daryl Simba cool magic sometimes I guess
outcome universe boobs again and at the
end of the day it turns out man was the
real monster all along it's a formula I
can totally get about oh the next one's
already started so if you ever wanted a
show to put images in your head they
would match the phrase porcupine wedding
sexy so glad Irene is on Sonic or
magical hysterectomy
then you are super weird like us and we
finally have a show to enjoy together
because at peak TV was all about 12-hour
movies you have to bench all at once to
appreciate then I welcome the return of
shows that could say tonight on Witcher
meet a bog monster who's also a
beautiful lady coming up after an
all-new Buffy Oh Joe you directed a John
on this one you're saying to make that
more and more obnoxious yes there's a
great just escalating because it's it
kind of just starts at like he just does
the epic voice and then he kind of just
twists the epic voice up a little bit
and then we just kept keep going yeah
that'll just kept letting the air out of
the balloon and so we got there it's
great yeah I missed good like TV promos
now they're all the same
either get none or it's like like NBC's
are all like depressing it's like
we go to Chicago fire it's like it's all
just grimdark marches did you think
enough adopted siblings had been
murdered or taken by disease on this is
us yeah you were wrong
this week on this is us I've only
watched the good doctor through the
promos for the good doctor for other
shows on ABC it's just progressed from
like how is this guy gonna be my doctor
to like he must choose between these
four women who this little boy dying my
favorite were always Mad Men because
Matthew wire had contempt for doing
promos but they told him that he had to
so like all of the next week on Mad Men
episodes it was all just like character
saying one word out of context it was
like Don saying yes and thinking of
being like I'm out of here and then you
know it do it be like the kid like Roger
say you have to make a decision like you
have to make a decision cut to like you
know Joan being like I don't think so in
consequence aligns like one after the
other it was this his way of telling AMC
like I'm not gonna tell you what's
happening next week and but screw you
I'm making my if you could find
themselves their best movie of the day
promos when I used to tape movies from
TV like I can still tell you like where
those commercial breaks and promos were
like Jack Burton teams up with Gracie
law to defend girls with green eyes on
feature of chat on the big 58 god stuff
so much yes don't make them like these
two they don't but we do let's silently
watch starring together yes only on
starring silent but deadly the hunchback
of notre dev hey Siri my bandits bring
another coin to the bad blood sugar X
magic bass beheadings bar midsummer
[Applause]
talking about coin how much coin feel
cakey more than you seem to find coin
pretty charming yourself I have enough
coin to rebuild their friends always got
exact change I respect even my coin
my coin coin talking about destiny you
don't believe in destiny I have to find
my destiny it's your destiny it's a
girly thing yeah go but what you think
it's like all of the things it's destiny
barfing and the F word yep mmm right
neuro yeah that's all you need I'll talk
about the girl I knew named destiny
later that's or a different video yeah
good gun and that's all but got out of
your head
[Music]
and it's back the hair which project
okay you just buried a baby at low tide
barely an inch into the same you might
as well just chuck them to the ocean em
you're not gonna put some elbow grease
into it yeah baby burying physics dan
was this your idea yes just the thinnest
layer same body that's really right back
up anytime I can get Joe Bluth into a
trailer I'm happy to plus that is one of
my favorite Arrested Development jokes
just the fact that joke doesn't know
anything works what you liked there's so
much amazing about that so yes that was
my my pitch there you go well the
perfect cherry on top of this Sunday
let's watch the deleted scenes what was
not good enough for the sunday story
Aragorn
this sword in the stone face hot tub
killing machines looking like a hunt
snack magic the flattering sandwich
because she's Circe Roman that's the
spells lasting dead lion knob doing
blood and mug what's that stench
so keep more guts Buffy the Vampire
Slayer
critical swole ragamuffin
oh that reminds me I gotta take my safe
word and I will work in a Spaceballs
reference anytime I go to my luggages
great all right that was fun let's talk
about what y'all had to say mmm
Danny Oh seeker one I read that as
DiGiorno Sita Jordan one you will find
it right honest I can't tell if this is
awful or not is it worth watching
I do think you'll know within the first
three or four episodes what I did worth
watching for you oh you didn't know you
didn't you didn't know wow you're the
Ken bone of this tape we have a few
questions for garel are you for real and
why explain all this yeah okay well I
think you'll you'll know sooner or later
and if this didn't help make up your
mind I think you should watch it give it
a try it's Game of Thrones directed by
Sam Raimi yeah I would thus far until I
would not tell you not to watch it yeah
I'd like the guy from UW who watch less
than I did I think we covered this
Domino bell writing for do you think
there's a better way the show could have
adapted the book series or a better
method of laying out a good season one
story instead of jumping timelines
constantly I don't see the reason why
they had to jump timelines I'd I really
think they could have gotten the same
thing across linearly but I'm sure they
have the reasons there were a couple of
satisfying moments that like I thought
paid it off but I do think the
transitions needed to be more clear
drunker yeah Emily Leone writes
I love yes yeah who was your favorite
character of the series let's play a
game called I'm almost through my third
watch and I don't know anyone's names
but I like you Anna for a lot especially
by the end of the series but I also like
Lady Dumbledore that works at bonanni
made 2-fold made sculptress yeah the hog
rats ha credits Hogwarts Academy of lava
Illuminati and I like her I like girl in
first episode that Witcher has to kill
after having sex with she's cool yes and
tris was it the he has the cool sword
fight with yeah so is that Tris yeah
okay
she'll be back okay good I thought she
was great and I was very sad when she
ate it probably them those three I like
them a lot I mean it rises or Falls with
Geralt for me and III would watch him
grunt his way through you know driving
school yeah he is bizarrely charismatic
for such like yeah and that that's
another reason why I think Campbell's
doing it on purpose just like yep well
there you go I hope we get I hope we can
do season two I hope they turn around
quickly I don't know how long this took
for them to make but I'm ready for more
witcher more winch and stuff mm-hmm and
I'm ready for the witcher 4 come on get
on that guys i know you have the other
big games other games yes okay yeah and
it's fine if you start with three
they're all sequels to the books so the
show i won't the show won't spoil
anything okay and you won't need to it's
fine just play the games okay and you
play the games and you play the games
and you come back next week because we
are getting so naughty we're getting so
dirty whoa
that's cool we are getting real real
adult next week and i think you'll know
why when you see us right here same time
same place for australian commentaries
thanks so much for watching bye bye
[Music]
you